hello and welcome to this
second u.s election special from
spectator tv we're delighted so many of
you
83 000 of the last count and rising
turned into our first discussion of the
us presidential race
special thanks to those of you who gave
us feedback and helpful comments
please continue to do so now if you like
the spectators take on all things
american
spectator tv viewers can get 10 of a
subscription
to our us website and our beautiful
monthly print edition all you have to do
is go to spectator.us
forward slash subscribe enter the promo
code
tv not that hard to remember we're even
going to throw in
a free whiskey tumbler whiskey tumbler
when you uh subscribe i mean what more
can we do
this week we'll discuss the new battle
for the supreme court the role of cancel
culture
in this presidential election as well as
the intervention
of those famed political experts harry
and meghan
a sense of barbara couple added their
two cents
to this year's election now to start i'm
delighted that we're joined
by david a kaplan author of the most
dangerous branch
inside the supreme court in the age of
trump douglas murray associate editor of
the spectator and author
of the madness of crowds as well as the
spectators
washington editor amber aka our
economist correspondent kate andrews
she's an american
who got lost in london and ended up at
spectator headquarters
and the spectators u.s editor
freddie gray welcome to you all let's
get going our first topic of course
is the death of ruther bader ginsburg
we learned that this legendary american
jurist and
feminist heroine she died this week at
the age of 87
after a long battle with cancer the news
instantly triggered
a political firestorm as democrats
warned that donald trump
will exploit her death to push through
his nominee
before the election and thus give the
highest court in the land
a strong majority of right-of-center
justices
and mr trump julie obliged by promising
he would announce his nominee this
weekend and adding that it would be
a woman the strong favorite is amy coney
barrett she's
a conservative catholic given the
almighty first
that occurred over mr trump's last
supreme court nominee
brett kavanaugh i'm pretty sure we can
expect
more of the same let's turn to our first
guest david a
kaplan david i suspect this supreme
court fight is going to turn
pretty nasty pretty quickly
it's a good bet but i wouldn't be sure i
think it is entirely conceivable
that democrats wanting to keep the
electoral focus on the pandemic
realizing they don't have the votes to
block this nomination
i could imagine them standing down you
could even imagine
a boycott of of the committee hearings
as at least was suggested for the
kavanaugh hearings now i don't think
senators are going to
will ultimately want to give up free air
time we'll give up the microphone but i
think it's possible
and of course biden has a real dilemma
trying to figure out how much capital to
expend
on these hearings which are are
presumably a lost cause
because every day spent discussing the
supreme court
is the day not spent discussing the
pandemic which is his strongest argument
to win it's interesting
that uh there may not be huge political
mileage in this for the democrats they
expended a lot of
political capital way back trying to
stop
kavanaugh becoming the supreme court
justice
it didn't work are they worried that
that may happen again then that they
they can't stop it and they're just
going to waste political capital in
trying to do so
well it's a different time 2018 was not
a presidential
election year and once the disclosures
from
christine blasey ford came out
they thought they had a real chance to
scuttle that nomination and had senator
susan collins of maine
gone the other way they would have
killed that nomination assuming nothing
comes out about this nominee whether
it's judge barrett
or judge lagoa they may decide with
five weeks to go or three weeks to go
if the confirmation rings begin in
mid-october
they may decide we need to keep a laser
focus on the pandemic
and that issue because taking the white
house is the key prize
now there's always an argument when a
justice dies
in a presidential year and the argument
is should the
existing the sitting president make the
attempt to make the nomination
or should they wait until the people
have had their say in the election the
republicans
famously used their senate majority to
block barack obama's uh
nominee marilyn garland claiming that
people should be able to
express themselves on the ballot um this
is precisely the argument democrats are
using now
i mean is this just politicians being
politicians being hypocritical
well that's that's redundant so yeah of
course it is
the the problem with the republican
response
is that you can't have it both ways they
argued x
in 2016 and they're arguing not acts
in 2020 the distinctions between well
you know in 2016
it was a democratic president and a
republican senate whereas this time
uh the republicans controlled both is
ridiculous
it doesn't even it doesn't even survive
the laugh test
the argument last time the core of the
argument was
in an election year you wait until the
election to give the people a say now i
didn't
i thought the argument was was
wasn't strong because of course the
people had their say
when they elected barack obama in 2012
you served for president
for four full years not three years
so i didn't think much to the argument
and i don't think much of the argument
now
um i think if the if on a clean slate
the president has every right to make a
nomination
you know right up until the end of his
term the senate has every right uh
to to vote either way the problem is the
hypocrisy as you point out
you can't argue what you said in 2016
and then with a straight face argue
otherwise now the more honest argument
not the not that honesty um is the coin
of the realm in politics
is simply saying we have the power this
is a power play
we're going to exercise our power that
at least um
is straightforward the problem of course
with power plays
is that when democrats raise the specter
now of packing the court
should they retake the white house and
the senate
elicits howls and yelps from republicans
court packing has precedent in american
history
unlike what the republicans did in 2016
and increasing
the size of the court come 2021
which i think democrats may well do is
entirely contemplated by the
by the constitution it's been done and
when republicans
scream bloody murder that this is
counter to history
and counter to what the constitution
requires um
i hope nobody's listening david
i want to come back to that about what
the democrats could do if they win the
white house and
the senate in november but before i do
i mean given that ginsburg was such an
iconic
um popular figure in the democratic
party
would it not uh would it not
for mr biden galvanize his base
if he was seen to make a big fight of
trying to stop
whoever mr trump nominates maybe i'm not
smart enough
uh um to say for sure what the politics
are
maybe it's galvanizing for the democrats
and maybe it's galvanizing
for the republicans and you could easily
imagine
that trump makes his nomination but does
not
ultimately want a vote before election
day because that might motivate
on the fence republicans in independence
to come out on election day
in theory to support the nominee now i
could backfire
if trump loses or or republicans lose
the senate
on election day it makes it a lot harder
for a vote thereafter to confirm trump's
nominee
to look anything other than unseemly so
there's a risk
but you know in 2016 we saw
from poland that the supreme court was a
more important issue
for republicans than democrats and about
a quarter of trump voters
who otherwise were repulsed by him
his policies and him personally said
because of the supreme court they would
vote for him a
certain percentage of hillary clinton
supporters said the same thing but
republican voters found the court
to be often decisive in 2016. they got
what they wanted
neil gorsuch and brett kavanaugh will
democrats feel similar
feel similarly because it's ginsburg or
because now it seems like roe v
wade is really on the line hard to tell
you could argue it either way
the latest pose though suggests that
this time round the democrats feel more
strongly about the supreme court
than the republicans the little bit of
polling we've seen
since she died um last friday bear that
out
but it's a snapshot you may see
differently in a week you may see
differently in a month and anecdotally
i mean we know and i know from having
reported
on the court for decades that
ever since roe v wade in 1973 the court
has been galvanized
galvanizing for the right and and
democrats
and liberals have never quite came to
grips with the fact
that while roe constitutionalized
abortion and was a major
uh victory in social policy it it helped
to radicalize
the republicans of the united states you
can make the argument you can't prove it
but you can make the argument and i do
in my book that but for roe v wade in
1973
we would never have gotten ronald reagan
that you might still have um what were
what were known as rockefeller
republicans
in the united states what passes uh for
moderates but
the party largely with the support of
previously
uninvolved politically uninvolved
evangelicals
uh shifted that party to the right and
helped
elect reagan in 1980 and ever since
has helped rally the party around it's
time to overturn roe
they may get what they want i think with
this nomination
but they should beware as well because
if abortion becomes entirely illegal
in many states you may see uh i'm
organizing on on the part of of of the
democratic party that we haven't seen in
a generation
david stick with us you raise some
fascinating points i want to bring in
kate
uh first here kate do you is there any
possibility in your view that even with
a
conservative majority mr trump gets this
person through i think it would then be
six
three on the court conservative majority
is there any possibility that uh the
court would
could then overturn roe v wade which
would make
essentially abortion illegal in the
united states
it is possible it's certainly a fear
that
the democrats and any pro-life person
will be thinking about but i think it
feeds into
broader concerns about the political
balance of the court and just how
political it's
begun i think sorry just how political
it's
become ruth bader ginsburg quite
famously wasn't a fan
of the roe v wade ruling that landmark
supreme court case that
made abortion a constitutional right not
because she was
pro-life indeed she was very pro-choice
but she thought that it was structured
on a poor argument
structured on a woman's right to privacy
and she thought
it should have been founded
constitutionally in gender equality so
she
knew that it was always on shaky ground
and i think what you could see
because roe v wade and the abortion
debate has become
so political as david says there could
be a meaningful attempt to overturn it
and uh ruth bader ginsburg was pointing
this out over the years but i think this
goes far past
roe v wade it just speaks to how
entrenched american institutions are
with
this political agenda right left
there it's all feeding in through the
institutions now and
this mudslinging i think you see between
republicans and democrats and the
hypocrisy on both sides flipping
arguments
that they were making in 2016 to try to
get their judge appointment
to get their judge appointed just shows
uh how important this decision has
become and how the constitutional
decisions in the us
are very much determined by politics
these days
amber what do you make of what are the
politics of this how does
how does the pulse politics we're not
going to have a
battle for a supreme court nomination
it's a
outside america it's quite hard to
understand because courts and other
democracies
tend to be separate from the political
system in america
the courts the federal courts supreme
court the district courts the appeal
course
they become highly political this is a
political battle
how does it play out in the election
campaign right well as david mentioned
uh this is really rare to see a supreme
court vacancy
galvanize democrats more so than
republicans but
the problem is is once we get to these
confirmation hearings if the democrats
overplay their hand like they did with
kavanaugh then we could see that flip
entirely
i can't tell you how many republicans
and conservatives i've spoken to over
the past two years
who describe themselves as being
radicalized by
the allegations that were made against
kavanaugh from the gang rape allegations
to um all the other stuff dating back to
college where he was accused of throwing
ice at someone
if the democrats come in and try to
level similar
um bunk accusations against amy coney
barrett maybe they won't be sexual
assault maybe there'll be something else
from her teenage years
then that could be something that
republicans certainly carry into
election day the other calculation that
democrats have to make
is how much are they going to go after
coney barrett for her faith
she is of course a very faithful
catholic well
joe biden is also apparently a catholic
although he doesn't follow a lot of the
church's teachings
so if some of the loudest democrats in
the senate
are on the record um accosting amy coney
barrett for the fact that she follows
things like the church's teaching on
abortion or on birth control
how is that going to reflect back on the
fact that they nominated someone who was
supposedly a catholic
so we've already seen articles come out
from places like newsweek and reuters
accusing amy coney barrett of being
a part of a catholic group that was the
inspiration for the handmaid's tale
if they continue that you can see a lot
of catholic voters in the midwest
start to think to themselves maybe joe
biden and the democrats are not actually
our champion
interesting point uh douglas has it
become in modern times
that these battles over supreme court
nominations which can turn
pretty nasty uh these days and uh and
are highly divisive
in the states do we now see this as part
of the cultural wars of america
well they certainly are but they're not
a new phenomenon i think most uh
observers would probably trace this back
to 1987
and president reagan's attempt to uh get
uh judge robert bork uh nominated to the
supreme court
uh anyone who's ever seen and and of
course it's all on youtube like
everything these days
um anyone who's seen the the hearings
and what uh senator kennedy teddy
kennedy in particular put
judge walk through can't help but
recognize that this is a precursor to
the
to the type of culture war battles that
are going on at the moment
where accusations are leveled about a
person's character
which don't even particularly need to be
backed up by any evidence
but as long as they are accused of the
the now very common heresies of the time
that's enough to get the person
basically uh out or at least uh
smeared enough to not want to go forward
uh so i think this has been going on
since 1987 i think that that was a
particular low point and i think ever
since then it's been inevitable these
nominations each time they come round
get as dirty as they do so it's
it is it is a a terrible phenomenon but
it's not completely new
freddie is it an advantage or a
disadvantage to mr
trump that he's now got this supreme
court
nomination battle playing out during the
election campaign
well i think trump will like it on one
level
in that it shakes things up and he needs
to shake things up if he's to catch
biden in the polls and he likes to keep
things as he famously told someone about
a real estate deal
nice and complicated and this certainly
does that
and and i think therefore if he can use
this
nomination to create a sense of culture
war as
happened with kavanaugh i think it could
be very beneficial to him
however there is a big negative for him
which is that
a lot of independents are being
persuaded by this trumpist argument
which is
if you don't vote for me if biden gets
in the radical left are going to take
over
and they will utterly destroy america
and if you look at what's happening with
the riots it's quite a compelling
argument however
if they stack the court in a
conservative direction
it could mean a lot of independents
start to think well what can biden do
there's a there's a supreme court to
check him
uh and to prevent this sort of radical
takeover that we're being warned of so
i think it's a very mixed bag for trump
but as i say his main instinct is he
likes to stir up the culture wars
we're already seeing it so far he's
going to push ahead with it and he's
going to try and cause
uh a real battle david let me come back
to you
it's not that long ago that you needed a
super majority to get your nomination
through the senate you needed 60 out of
100 votes to get
the nominee confirmed for the supreme
court it's now just a simple majority
has that made the whole
nomination process more ideological
more extreme playing to the bases
playing to the extremes of the party
because you don't need to put together a
60 votes that may involve some
compromises
of course when the filibuster required
60 votes
and earlier 67 votes
you were forced to find somebody closer
to the middle
if you only need 50 plus one and you're
the party in control you can pick
somebody
as as radical um as you like
uh you know without relitigating robert
bork was a
really smart guy one of the best legal
minds in america
he was not picked for that reason it was
a nice
thing it was a nice attribute but he was
picked
because of his radical views on
constitutional law which is entirely
reasonable if you agree with those views
but
apart from teddy kennedy's demagogy
apart from him going over the line the
brief against bork in 1987 was
largely on the merits the irony of
course
is that antonin scalia the year before
was every bit as conservative
but hadn't put it down in writing there
was a battle over the chief justice
seat so so scalia you know waltzed on
through almost
um unanimously there is absolutely
nothing wrong in my view
with evaluating nominees based on their
ideologies
based on how you think they're going to
vote the notion and will hear it during
the upcoming hearings that somebody's
qualified they went to a fine law school
they clerked for a
supreme court justice they teach at a
great law school
they work at a great law firm that makes
them qualified utterly misses the point
and is disingenuous
of course they're capable of doing the
job
but that's not the sole criterion on
which to judge
and when the president and the
federalist society in this case
that organization of conservative law
students and faculty members and lawyers
when they are picking somebody
specifically for their ideology a
prediction
of how they'll vote on abortion or
obamacare and a range of other social
issues then it's entirely reasonable
for senators and activists to similarly
evaluate a nominee
on that basis but but i wanted to
to make a larger point and particularly
when you refer to
the judicial tradition in other
countries i argued in my book in a way
that infuriated
um liberals and conservatives my own
wife disagreed with half my book
you must be wrong man well you're right
i mean i
i argue that that
the largest problem of the supreme court
of the last 50 years that it is simply
too involved
in too many areas of american life and
the court would be better
turning away cases because they control
the justices control their own docket
they would better off i'll be better off
pointing across the street at the
capitol and saying you know it's up to
congress
or pointing to lower state to state
courts or state legislatures
and say it's up to you just because
you're asked to get involved
doesn't mean you should and sometimes
the best kind of judging
is when you decide not to decide
and i argue in the book they should have
done that in the case in the in in the
case of abortion
but they also should have done that in
2000 in bush fee gore
when the court stepped in to resolve a
disputed presidential election
they should have done it for gun control
voting rights they should have done it
in a range of areas
and and and the the benefit of that
would it would be it would lower
would reduce the importance of the court
and it would lower the temperature of
confirmation hearings
you know the conservatives are ascendant
now so they like a powerful supreme
court yes
they didn't 40 years ago and
you know that's the problem and i
interviewed a majority of the
of the justices for my book it was on
background i can't tell you
uh who they were but when they would ask
me at the beginning of a conversation
could you summarize
what the point of your book is and i
would say well
you guys are involved in too many things
i had one of the liberals and one of the
conservatives each say to me with a
smile
will i half agree with you that's the
problem
david i've got one we're over running on
this but it's such been such an
important topic this
week it's fascinating to hear you let me
ask you one final question
suppose mr trump gets his 6-3 majority
in the supreme court but on election day
uh the democrats win the white house and
the senate
what is the likelihood of the chances in
your view
of the democrats then trying to stack
the supreme court there have been nine
members
of the supreme court since 1869 in the
possible
war era it doesn't specify nine
in the constitution it can be changed
fdr
in 1937 because the supreme court was
blocking
a lot of the new deal legislation or the
interpretation of it
looked at stacking it it kind of
backfired on him he didn't go ahead with
it
but the supreme court did change his
behavior and look more kindly
on a lot of that new deal legislation
what are the chances that it could go to
15 members
to give the democrats a majority this
time the the court has changed its
roster seven
times in american history not since 1869
but seven times so the idea that
that increasing the size of the court is
a historical
or is trampling on the constitution as
the white house spokeswoman said
yesterday
um is idiotic it's just wrong does it
politicize the court
sure so does blocking merrick garland's
appointment
in 2016 and so does what's going on now
and there's an argument to be made you
don't have to be a nobel laureate in in
game theory
in it to realize that sometimes the way
you respond is tit-for-tat
you've got to respond to a bully by
being a bully
otherwise you're a sucker and i think
the democrats
who usually demonstrate that they are
really bad
at playing bad they're just not as good
at hardball as republicans
i think there is a growing consensus
that if they take control in 2021 they
will attempt to court
attack the court and i argued actually
on
in in a new version of my book that came
out last year
that that was finally what democrats
ought to do i resisted that because i
think it's bad for the court
it will eliminate any notion that the
court is independent and neutral
and rules on some basis different than
what legislatures or the president
does so i think in the short term it's
destructive of the court's prestige
my hope would be that in five or 50
years
after the republicans have
counter-packed when they took power and
then perhaps the democrats
counter pack and maybe you have a court
you know of
21 justices who knows you may eventually
have to put ryanair seats
up on the bench but my hope would be
that in time
both sides would come to realize that
disarmament
is the way to go and that maybe we need
to de-politicize the court and instead
of looking
for judges who will simply be proxies
for the partisan views of presidents
maybe we look to find
judges in another tradition those who
attempt
to apply the more the law more neutrally
and more independently and you can find
any number
of of justices in american history not
that long ago
who behave that way would that reform
take place
i'm not sure but i think the only chance
of de-politicizing
uh the court is for the democrats in
2021 to respond in kind
my predictions are almost always wrong i
was right with kavanaugh
i was right with scalia uh 30 plus years
ago
i've been wrong almost every other time
but i think court packing will happen
david that's fascinating we shall see
what happens it does of course i mean
the democrats have to win the white
house and
the senate first david a kaplan author
of the most dangerous branch inside the
supreme court in the age of trump
thank you for joining and uh sharing
your insights with the audience of
spectator tv
us election special council culture and
the election now in 2016
mr trump won the presidency in no small
part because he waged war on
political correct correctness there were
lots of americans
not just republicans they were dying to
hear a candidate who spoke
frankly bluntly even shockingly about
the big issues of the day
since mr trump's election the phrase
cancel culture has emerged
uh it refers to the phenomenon of people
being censored
banned handed off social media out of
their jobs
having expressed the quote wrong point
of view
president trump had a big speech at
mount rushmore and
in his convention address uh well he
took aim at cancer culture not
surprisingly and his team
seemed eager to make it a centerpiece of
his campaign
it helps to energize the base he's also
banning federal agencies from teaching
critical race theory no
i'm not sure what that is either douglas
let's come to you first
how big is cancel culture
in the united states is it over
exaggerated by the right
or is it a growing phenomenon in
american public life
um it's both of these things there are
people who
exaggerate the extent to which a thing
called council culture
exists and like a lot of other terms in
our era like fake news
they're both uh specific and too flabby
to be used because people
mean different things when they refer to
them on the one hand cancel culture can
refer to people who do get hounded
out of their jobs from expressing a view
on social media
that may well be for instance perfectly
mainstream but an employer might decide
that the attention
isn't worth the fuss likewise it's used
to describe
online campaigns against large
corporations and
and much more boycotts all of this so
it's become
a term which is uh it envelops quite a
number of ideas
uh i think that the thing in it which
has caught on is something that people
do recognize and that is a general
feeling that there are opinions that are
totally mainstream indeed on occasion
majority
opinions uh that have become almost
unexpressable in the political
mainstream without
coming under at least significant
pressure and
and it's that sense the sense is not new
again
it it's something that's been around for
a while you could claim that it's a
version of political correctness gone
not just mad but political correctness
with uh with heavier weaponry
uh uh so it's not entirely new it comes
from a
familiar idea but that is generally that
that people
fear that they can't express themselves
about certain things now in america
there's an added uh issue with this now
and that is
the cancellation of history it's not
only happening in america it's happening
in britain and elsewhere as well
but that is a sense that everything to
do with american history
is also at risk of alleged cancellation
and that's not such a crazy idea
uh the 1619 project uh it was created by
the new york times as an ongoing project
it won a pulitzer
which it actually said that it wanted to
bring the
the idea the understanding of how
america was founded forward more than
around a century and a half uh to the
first time that uh
slaves were brought into america from
africa this week
that uh has itself been the subject of a
massive culture war because the founders
of the 1619 project
were accused of cancelling part of their
own founding documents
and them were themselves pushing back
against this but the point is
it's it's it's a tussle that is going on
about everything not just in the present
but in the past and there's a lot in it
are we seeing a phenomenon here where as
younger people
uh come out of the campus come out of
university
move into jobs we maybe this is what we
saw at the new york times
where there was a huge row there
involving cancer culture
that they are bringing with them the
culture the cancer
culture of the campus into the
institutions where they now work is
that's what is that what is happening
yes there used to be a conservative
critique you might even say conservative
joke
about certain campuses and certain uh um
studies in campuses in the us in
particular which was that
people went away to university and did
sort of basically useless degrees
uh that is they know they studied uh
critical race theory
feminist dance and uh queer theater for
instance
and the the conservative critique of
this conservative joke used to be
well they're going to find out the hard
way the um the market is going to assert
itself
these people aren't going to have jobs
to go to and that turned out to be flat
out wrong
uh the conservative joke wasn't very
funny and the conservative
hope that gravity would assert itself
didn't happen
these people had a lot of jobs to go to
they flooded through the hr departments
of major corporations
every corporation in the us is now
desperately reaching out for people
uh of this ilk who can who can fill
their companies and tell them
that they don't know anything very much
and should educate themselves
um so so actually the joke is on
everyone else
and and and it's and it's real i mean
what you just
the phrase you just used earlier
critical race theory uh
only a few years ago was it was a
ghettoized concept in a small number of
uh liberal universities in the us
and now we're in a situation where
almost everyone on earth has to start
contending with it
even if they can't understand it because
most people can't understand it because
it actually doesn't make any sense on
its own terms but that's another
discussion
amber how does mr trump play this
do is advantage is it really
mainstream i mean i know we're all
obsessed with
who's running the op-ed page of the new
york times and
uh who runs it whatever but it does
do real people really care
can mrs trump make this a mainstream
issue
i think what trump really taps into is
this really
basic tenet of americanism which is
the uh extreme love of
free speech and what he's able to do
because of the fact that he's such a big
celebrity and
and because he's made so much money is
that he's basically uncancelable
so he is able to speak his mind and
never apologize for anything offensive
he might say
and that's something that really appeals
to a lot of people who feel like
they have to keep their politics or
their
deepest most innermost thoughts under
wraps for fear of
reprisal from their peers uh trump is
not the only person who
has the celebrity to be uncancelled well
the other person is actually
kanye west who despite um being a black
man to don maga hat
against you know so many other rappers
in in hollywood and in the music
industry
has still managed to have best-selling
albums
even creating a gospel album um that was
remarkably successful
so people see them as really uh icons of
um just a basic sense of being an
american
kate does this cancel culture of
business doesn't it play into
what was already upon the culture wars
in 2016
when there was all this talk of the
coast of the elites on the east and the
west and then the rest of america
was flyover country um the the
cancelling
is happening overwhelmingly among the
coastal elites that's the people who are
arguing
about it and for those who live in the
so-called flyover country
it just seems bizarre so and i guess in
a way it does play
to mr trump's narrative of energizing
his base for this election
yeah i think you can argue in a strange
way that canceled culture
does help president trump because it
reaffirms what his base already believes
which is that the other side doesn't
want to debate and sees debate as a
fundamentally disagreeable
and bad thing and they do have some
evidence to back that up you had the
house speaker nancy pelosi suggesting
less than a month ago
that joe biden should not debate
president trump because he quote
belittles
those kinds of debates now where to even
begin with that the idea that the
american people shouldn't hear from the
american president
democratically elected president in
election year or that
somehow people are going to be worse
informed because they
hear the people that they're going to go
out and vote for speak and debate
you know it's hard to add up and i think
that works for the president because it
means people who don't like him who find
him deeply offensive and grotesque
often if they do as amber says have have
a soft spot and really support free
speech
end up defending him they don't want to
defend him they don't like what he's
saying but they do believe in his right
to say it
so i think a lot of his opponents will
still have that caveat there and of
course that
that helps the president i also think a
lot of these very extreme
right-wing views any sympathy towards
fascism or white supremacy are extremely
marginal i think for most of us there's
this guttural instinct that you just
don't want to be in any way associated
with those views the fear of course is
that cancer
cancer culture actually gives people
with deeply unsavory views more of a
platform
because it's quite easy to ignore people
who have really gross views
but if you cancel them you might turn
them into a celebrity you give them a
lot of air time and then
actually quite moderate people who
support free speech might find them
sympathizing with people
who have much more extreme views and i
think that is one of the dangers of
cancel culture
but to your point andrew i do think it
feeds in to the president's
rhetoric about the other side and about
his opponents but of course if you don't
have the money
and the celebrity status and and the
title of president
as donald trump does and you are just a
normal person getting cancelled that can
ruin your life so it's one thing to use
it as an election tactic but
in real life it's hugely painful freddie
the number of cases of people being
cancelled is growing they've been some
particularly egregious examples one
was the young liberal democrat pollster
who had the temerity to point out that
polling in 1968 showed that the riots
helped the republicans help nixon to get
elected not the democrats
uh which seems a strange reason to
cancel anybody but he lost his job
these are individual cases i thought
amber mentioned 1619
and that sounded to me as an example
of what's happening in the cultural wars
even more important i would suggest
that individuals being cancelled it
seems in the end the purpose of 1690
was to reframe all of american history
around slavery
now there is no question in the study of
american history slavery has often been
underplayed
but this was an attempt to put slavery
at the center
of american history so much so that part
of the articles
argue that the whole american revolution
began because of slavery
they thought the brits were going to
abolish slavery so therefore they better
get rid of the brits so they could
protect slavery so
even the most seminal event in american
history
the foundation of america the end of it
being 13
colonies and becoming the united states
of america
was done to preserve slavery that
seems to me for lots of americans
to be really uh an argument
that they would want to have and that
they won't go along with and more
important than a few individuals being
cancelled
a good example of that is the fact that
the uh new york times at one stage after
the 1619 project got
going the new york times had serious
editorial discussions about whether
every time they used the word america
they should put comma a nation that was
founded on slavery and white oppression
comma and this was seriously discussed
as something that the new york times
would have to do
every time they used the word america or
the united states which
which shows the extent to which this
pathology has gripped
a large part of of the left and the
center left in america but
getting away from the media i would also
say there's a there's an interesting
phenomenon which one of our writers
bridget fertezi has talked about a lot
which is micro cancellations
and what she means by that is the number
of voters in america who will have felt
during a conversation with their family
or in the office
or perhaps with friends that something
they think
is no longer acceptable and there are
there's increasing fear
among a lot of americans about what they
can say out loud in certain places
and that is something that can have a
serious impact on elections
and i think we underestimate that as our
peril um one thing we've done recently
on
spectator us is we've we've looked at a
lot of
uh secret suburban trump moms we'd call
them
and we did a piece from the from one of
them saying you know i can't admit to
liking donald trump in in the social
circles i move in because it's
unacceptable
and then we have this huge flood of
emails from
secret suburban trump mum saying i'm one
of these people too
and so i wonder whether this is a small
indication of a much bigger phenomenon
that will
play itself out in november okay we
shall see
and we will return to it as well uh it
certainly is a key part of the cultural
wars in the united states
now this week a couple living in santa
barbara california made a video
appearance
for the time magazine from their 14
million
dollar home they issued a special plea
to americans to vote in what they called
the most
important election of all time we can
see a bit of that now
every four years we are told the same
thing that this
is the most important election of our
lifetime
but this one is when we vote our values
are put into action and our voices are
heard
it's vital that we reject hate speech
misinformation and online negativity
yes it was harry windsor and his wife
megan
also known as the duke and duchess of
sussex
of course the last time british royalty
tried to tell americans what to do
it didn't really end that well maybe
they'll
have more success this time uh douglas
didn't quite save all for joel biden but
it was pretty obvious that's what he
meant was it not
yes it was it it's very hard to think
that the conclusion of their remarks
could ever have ended
so vote trump um or four more years
uh uh yes it's um the whole way that it
was framed was very much of the
um uh coastal uh progressive
democrat uh netflixy zeitgeist which
believes that
it's very obvious and that if you're a
good person
it's obvious who you vote for because
it's good versus bad
and uh it's it's it's not terribly
surprising i mean sometimes of course
when people say we're just talking
earlier about critical race theory and
all this sometimes people say has this
stuff really gone very far
and i would i would say this is the
latest example yes it's
it's even got to the head of harry
windsor
uh um so it's got very far indeed
it's gone it might not have been much to
stop at getting into that
it's possible the barriers aren't all up
but um
um but i i would just suggest suggest
you know this this stuff that that that
they have
imbibed is absolutely the same thing as
is being imbibed by college students
across the u.s and and the problem with
it is of course
is that it not only is it simplistic
it it doesn't allow for any brooking of
of what is normal democratic discourse
which is that
there are meaningful agreements that
your opponents have
uh meaningful reasons of their own to
believe things and you should try to
understand them
and it it it drops all of that it says
it's very obvious
it's it's straightforward and therefore
if you were to vote for trump you would
be doing something knowingly bad
and and i you know i i i i'm
not surprised particularly that uh um
the duchess of sussex uh takes his view
this is clearly a political view she's
had for a long time
it is rather surprising to see prince
harry voicing it as you say not least
because it's quite hard to see
whether there's an audience for him
saying that secondly because he also
sort of begs in the video of a rather
piteous bit where he says
many people won't know that i've never
had the right to vote
as if as if he was sort of living under
a
minuscule form of apartheid in britain
throughout his whole life
and that we have to pity his terrible
straightened circumstances
he's always lived in uh but also just
this this very strange thing
that they seem to think that that this
influencer position they've come to is
one that very many people want i'm not
sure maybe they will
i wouldn't myself and of course harry
did not have the right to vote in
britain because he's a member of the
royal family
the family doesn't get to vote he hasn't
got a right to vote in america
because he's not an american citizen yes
at least not so far
amber i'm working on the assumption that
americans
they hang on every word that they hear
from harry and me
well it's quite funny because you would
think megan would understand
how americans view british royalty but
she really doesn't seem to
i would say the average american
basically views them as
a very classy version of a hollywood
celebrity
um and one of the things that's most
appealing to americans about the royal
family is that
they really don't speak that much in
public they kind of just walk around and
look really pretty
so the fact that megan and harry are
constantly lecturing them about politics
really takes away
that intrigue that mystique that
americans do like about royals
and turns them into just your average
celebrity
that's coming out of hollywood and
trying to tell people how to think and
how to vote
obviously that didn't turn out so well
for hillary clinton in 2016 who had a
number of really high profile liberty
endorsements and actually mocked
president trump
for the fact that there are so few
conservative celebrities so
it really boggles the mind as to why
prince harry and megan would think that
this is a winning strategy
what i do know kate about a hollywood
celebrity
is that if you're a celebrity in
hollywood but you're not in the
entertainment business
you're not a celebrity for for long
hollywood that's all that matters i mean
they're not really in the entertainment
business despite
the deal from from netflix they may be a
diminishing uh um
phenomenon as celebrities they may be
you're right andrew but
not by uh they've certainly been trying
to break into it we'll see how
successful
they are but to echo amber's point
uh harry and megan traded the service
that they would have been performing in
the uk for the british people and the
public
to hollywood fame and once you step into
hollywood fame then you get the title
celebrity not royal and we did not see
celebrities have a huge impact in 2016
or even in 2018.
i don't think they sway as many hearts
and minds as they think they do
and actually i think very often it can
work against
them and and the party that they're
endorsing because i think your average
joe where jane out there
sees these celebrities usually in their
beautiful back gardens of their
multi-million dollar homes and they
think to themselves
you don't exactly represent me so i
think oftentimes weighing in can
actually have the adverse effect
well we have the person with us on this
special spectator tv broadcast who's
responsible
for it all that is freddie gray the
editor of spectator usa
in its very first print edition um
spectator
us put meghan markle on the cover
with an article from one of our star
writers rod
little saying pleading please america
take her back referring to megan well
clearly freddie gray the message was
hurt
and you are responsible for this
happening
and maybe americans now are beginning to
wish
that they hadn't taken them back well
the only thing we can do is next time do
a
we're sorry edition uh
because i'm sorry are you we we're not
that sorry but i'm not sorry enough to
take her back
uh but it was quite funny i spoke to an
american friend today
who said i mean this this shows how
americans treat royals i think we think
americans treat roles very seriously but
actually they regard them
as a bit of a joke i spoke to an
american friend and he said i really
want to meet harry and megan
so that when i see them i can say i saw
your video
and it really inspired me to vote for
donald trump
and i think that's that's how americans
see it they see
these silly people who know nothing
about politics
suddenly acting like they're michelle
and barack obama just because they both
got netflix tv deals
and they're acting as though they're in
a position to tell americans what to
think
and it's an uncomfortable position for
them because
americans don't take too kindly to it i
don't think
you used to be a fan of meghan markle
cave and so was i i
actually watched the royal wedding which
is not something i would normally do
because i rather like the idea of megan
marco and harry windsor getting
together as a modernization of the
monarchy what went wrong
well look she was an opinionated woman
who was willing to express those
opinions with an american accent in the
uk
so naturally i had to give her the
benefit of
the doubt but unfortunately i i think
having to take that back seat having to
not be
um the most important royal perhaps not
always
the one to to be in the spotlight may
have proved slightly difficult because
it strikes me for all the criticisms of
being in the media here in the uk
once they've gone to first canada and
now hollywood they can't seem to get
enough media attention and
certainly want to continue uh to put
their opinions out there
um but again once you abandon the royal
family
and you find yourself a hollywood
celebrity you're held up
as a celebrity and they don't have the
best track record when it comes to
politics over the past
five ten quite a few years actually
quite a few years hard to think of the
last time celebrity
really swayed the hearts and minds of
the american people maybe ronald reagan
actually
i just i just add to that of course
there is one giant
problem uh coming for the both of them
which is that the
uh the woke agenda that they have signed
up to uh has a lot of things in its
sites but one of them is privilege
most commonly heard when people say
check your privilege and i do worry that
there is going to come a day when
somebody says to prince harry that he
should check his privilege
and he won't have nearly enough time to
do so
he can say he never was able to vote so
how can you call him privilege
disenfranchised
if they're gonna take make videos like
the one they've done and take a a
part in public life and debate
essentially in politics which fights up
to them
if you want to do that but shouldn't
they think of giving up
the titles duke and duchess and just
become like the rest of us
douglas yes i think very much so i think
it's extremely uncomfortable
in the long term unsustainable position
um
and uh and yes and they have given up
bits of their uh
of their roles already uh currently they
seem to want the good bits without the
the boring bits as they steam to them
the unglamorous bits you know the
opening of hospitals the opening of
schools and church halls
um so no i i think that they that it it
it is a
an uncomfortable situation and i think
that most people just feel very sorry
for her majesty the queen
uh because there was so much promise in
prince harry he seemed to have so much
to give
and to have gone off to the west coast
and sold himself to netflix
it is probably not the future that many
people wished for him
now because we've been spending so much
time talking about the crucial issue of
harry megan we haven't got time to do
china but we'll do that
in subsequent editions of spectator tv
u.s election special let me just get in
the final five minutes or so let me get
just your update on where we are in the
election campaign and
let me come to you first how do you read
things so far i look at the national
poll
it's not moved that much mr biden is
seven or eight points ahead
i look at the real clear politics
average in
six battle ground states mr biden's on
average about 3.5 percent ahead that
hasn't changed
that much recently either what's
happening
yeah i did actually see a washington
post poll this morning in arizona and
florida that had
trump up one percentage point in arizona
and i believe it was three or four in
florida
um and washington post of course is not
exactly friendly to the president and
i'm sure was not really
over sampling republicans so it is a
good sign for trump
um i think obviously the battleground
states are the most important anyway
because that is where um those last 20
to 30 electoral votes needed to secure
the election are going to come from
uh and the fact that the polls are
pretty narrow even some of the more
liberal pollsters only have biden up by
four or five percentage points in some
of those states
is a really good sign for the president
considering uh that's pretty close to
within the margin of error
and back in 2016 a lot of these polls
ended up to be
ended up being disastrously wrong and a
lot of them do over sample democrats so
i think the trump campaign is probably
feeling pretty good about where they are
right now
okay where do you say things at the
moment not long to go
just uh coming up to about six weeks to
go
not long to go and i agree that the
polls are tightening in the battleground
states is
relatively good news for the president
but i also wouldn't want to overstate it
the most notable
state for me is pennsylvania real clear
politics now has biden up
by roughly i think three or four
percentage points that of course is his
home state so he should be over
performing there
that would be a worrying sign but we
know that broadly speaking for
not just the past few months but for
well over a year those independent
voters and a lot of women have been
gravitating towards
joe biden because they just see him as a
bit of a break from
what has been a really crazy four years
love it or hate it it has been
an absolutely it has been an absolute
roller coaster of a time
and the promises that people perhaps
thought they were sold that donald trump
might calm down a bit in office once he
was elected
hasn't panned out so my suspicion is
that joe biden's still feeling
relatively comfortable i do think
however a lot can change next week
when we go into that first presidential
debate joe biden has been struggling on
the campaign trail often
not with his messaging really but
getting out his messaging and his
communication
and i suspect that the president will be
ready to go for a very
feisty debate joe biden's going to have
to rise above that but he's also going
to have to match the president in terms
of
energy and tone and rigor and i think
that could be a bit of a challenge
douglas how do you read it as things
stand at the moment
um like a lot of people a few months ago
i wouldn't have given the president very
much of a chance
and now i think he's got a very good one
uh it that's
principally because of the riots the
disturbances
looting and much more that's gone on so
many american cities in recent months
and what i see is being the growth of
those people that are similar to the
ones that freddie referred to earlier
the the the people who wouldn't admit to
anyone
who they might be voting for but will
will slip into the into the booth and
and regretfully or or happily vote for
the person they didn't
tell anyone that they anticipated voting
for i think that is a very interesting
phenomenon this year as it was in 2016.
and i just added one other thing which
is uh when it comes to the debates i
mean i
have a very strong feeling that we will
know who has won this election within
the first 10 minutes of the first debate
uh joe biden has given speeches in
recent weeks which show that he
actually is much more limber and fitter
than president trump likes to pretend
that his opponent is in the various
rallies
a couple of nights ago to rally
president trump had great fun with the
crowd joking that
joe biden can't follow the teleprompter
and he trump doesn't even need a
teleprompter
we'll see if biden actually does in the
first minutes of the debate clearly
look like the candidate he would have
been certainly a few years ago
then i think most people will think that
that is indeed a safe option to some
extent
uh however if if trump is able to uh
shark around him in the manner similar
to that in which he managed with hillary
clinton in 2016
i think a lot of people will think that
the person who the democrats thought was
a safe candidate
uh was a false hope freddie i'll give
the last word to you as our u.s
editor um i'm struggling to see what has
yet
moved the dial through this month of
september which is when the campaign has
really
got going the uh the woodward book rage
on covet when he claimed that the
president knew how serious it was but he
covered it up
that didn't really move the the dial
because i think
a lot of people accepted the president's
explanation
two hundred thousand fatalities in
america all through
covert a huge number
that hasn't yet moved the dial either so
does it come down
to cleveland next tuesday night
and the first presidential debate i
think the debates will be important but
i think as you
as you point out a lot of the stories
that the media get very excited about
don't make that much of a difference on
the polls
but there are interesting things that
the the biden campaign and i think a lot
of conservative and trump supporting
pundits are missing that that are
favorable for biden
and one is his performance in states
that aren't the battleground states
so georgia for instance is looking quite
interesting for biden now which was
unexpected
arizona's looking in favor of biden so
you could see trump may be winning
a lot of these battleground states
they're crucial but slipping up in areas
where uh he didn't in 2016. so
so that will be interesting and i think
that
more more broadly on the debates
i i don't i don't necessarily feel
there's going to be this crunch moment i
suggested this last week
that there's going to be this crunch
moment where biden unless he does
something completely crazy
i think biden will be will be seen as
having had an okay debate so
i think biden is looking stronger in the
polls than i would have said
two or three weeks ago well i don't
think it matters what time zone you're
in if you're interested in american
politics you're going to be watching
live that cleveland uh debate it's going
to be show business i'm
thinking that's us for spectator tv this
second u.s election special thanks to
our guests thanks to the home team
thanks for all of you for tuning in i
remember if you want to hear more from
spectator journalists
um that we've had on the show subscribe
to the spectator's extensive american
coverage
spectator dot u s forward slash
subscribe
enter that code tv and you'll even get
a discount our next edition of the us
election spectator tv special will be
next week it'll follow
the cleveland debate and we'll be
bringing you up to speed on what
happened there
and what will happen after but for now
thank you and goodbye
you